[Musique]
on a fait voter à l'agglomération et à
l'unanimité
je pense que c'est une bonne chose le
principe justement d'avancé avec des
opérateurs sur le les trottinettes et
sur un maillage à l'ensemble des douze
communes
c'est un système de trottinette en
libre-service donc là en amont il faudra
d'abord une fois que l'opérateur sera
retenu et choisit définir les stations
qui seront des mots qui seront comment
dire identifié par un marquage au sol
avec des bornes évidemment donc il
faudra voir justement où est-ce qu'elles
soient implantées ou est-ce que cela
fait sens
c'est une expérimentation d'un an qui
sera reconductible deux fois ce qui nous
permet aussi de voir comment les choses
se passent sur le terrain et puis
ensuite de voir si on y va ou pas dans
la durée sur un mode de déplacement qui
veut qu'on pourra juger peut-être
pérenne et durable